[拍手]
[音楽]
えっ北海道帯広市から来ました農業増法設計者という小さい会社を営んでいます
浜田かっこいい
今日ですね帯広-10来とったそうですねええあの最初の話でですね
小里1月から12月にずらしたのに今雪が降ったみたいなことがあってですね
たぶん奥が雪男とったんじゃないかなった
あんまりちょっと自信ないんですかそう思っているところです8を崩しねあのには8
例えば農業機械
あのコレクターとかあぁ wiki とかあるいは今入っのそういう農業機械に付けて
えーっ here 白
できるだけ効率的に作業しいうようなそんな
農業機械用の gps 外となるでしょうね体[ __ ]ですか
gps ガイダンスシステムというものを作っています a
ここらが今作っているこの時期エースガイダンスシステムはどんなものか
それからこれからの農業ですねどうやって入っていけるかというようなことを話しでき
たら重い
それへと大作業もどうなことをやるんだろうってご存じない方のためにちょっと動画を
作りましたご覧いただければ想い
これ今ですねあ農薬を撒くところなんですけれどもこんな感じで
シュートを訳がわかりますよくいると分かりになるかもしれませんがどこまでやったか
走ってしまうと分かりません
タネをまいたりあるいは肥料をまいたり農業ってこういう存在で午後まで走ったか
わかんない作業って結構あります
それから今この制御を頑張ってくれて20メートルくらいあるん
端までになるこれ今20m ぴったりとなりを帰ってこなくてはいけません
重なるともちろん重なっただけも何買ってしまいますし
ほらアクトですね例えばそこから病害を発生してその一帯を全部
その巻き込んでしまう収穫できなくなってしまうということがあります
おまけに前だけ見て走ってるわけにいかないんですね後ろにこれもうするが運転席の
後ろノズルが付いています
あるいは種を蒔くところも後ろについてることが多いですなくなってしまったり
あるいは詰まってしまったりすることがありますそう
まったく作業になりませんですから後ろみたいにもあるこというでもちゃんとまっすぐ
場所
こう感覚に走ろうという非常に大変な作業です
えっ
それに対してですねもうすでにこういう形ってこれ海外から発売される gps
ガイダンスシステムというものがあります
雨があって度爪がしたらいいかがわかってそれから& root 化にですモーターが
付いてたりするものもありますハ話でも真っ直ぐ走る
しかしこういうもの自体はまだすごく高いです
大画面だけど後60万円しまうそして
もっと良い子精度の高い位置がわかるあるいはハンドルを手放しで走るようにする
アルト後山に200万300万になってしまうんです
エイ今や遺体遺棄1番代ぐらい以降流通費あの研究者でした
に水産省ですね同協議会の研究者ですその時に作ってたのはこういう
一同最近あのテレビドラマなんかでもですね
お目にかかったまあご覧になった方がいるかもしれません
僕はの車のラジコンガード趣味でですね
8が好きでレースとか出てたんですけど最後これらのスマホでコントロールできます
東都1分の1になったかと思って
すごい宇宙切れこういう仕事をしてたんですがもう一つの仕事は国産の地域イース
ガイダンスシステムというものを作るという仕事でした
そしてそれはうまくいかなかった
あの僕らがですね a 棟
マーキュリーたもの例えばちょっと国産のノートパソコンを使わなければいけないか
あるいは海外のちょっと高い塀に押せるような
egp 使ったということもあってちょっと泊していぱ系朝たからもう海外のもの
勝てませんそれはもう付き合っていけません言われました
研究所の中でもですねえっいつまでこんな売れないものを
やってるんだあるいはもう新しいことやった方がいいですよというのずいぶん
言われますでも僕自身はですねどうしてもやっぱこれ
通してもうちょっと続けたかった
えっなんでかっていうと一つだ自分が作ったものを
直接農業者の方々に逆に立ててもらいたかったというのも人それからもう一つがこの
これのこういう技術も先にもっとその新しい農業が持っている
思っ
僕この仕事をするちょっと前までそのその前まではのリー水産省というところに言い
ました
果物がかかる
果物を生産振興しようという係でした
そこで見たのが
食べる人を作る人が全然お互いのことは分からない
先ほど
方がご覧頂きましたけれども例えば畑でこういうことが起こってますよ
you
なかなかわかりませんこういうのが何て言うのかなあの
すべても
なんていうか下
お互いに意思が卒できないというかお互いのことがわかりにくいという源になっている
じゃないか
例えば
福さんキャベツができすぎました
畑の中につぎ込んで潰しますというニュースが出た時に
やはりパンの食べる人にとっても絶えないよねという話があるわけですが
作っている人にとってはどうしても
過ごさなければいけない
これ以上出荷すればするだけ赤字になってしまうということがあります
お互いのことがお互いのことをわかっていればあ残念だったねとかあるいは役に大策
だった時にはお腹いっぱい食べれてよかったねという話ができるかもしれません
それを下げ防災んだろう
そして僕がこれを見たときに将来この技術が食べる人とつくるひとつな技術になる
思いました
ええまあそれであきらめずにですねこういうことを続けて結局会社をつくって今まで
やってきたわけですけれども
僕らが作ったのこんな感じのアプリです
スマホ用のアプリになりまし
えっ android でルー
走ってる場所が分かりますどんな作業をしたかがわかるそれから上に数字が出ているん
ですけど何センチずれているか分かるのでハンドルをそれを見ながら
知ってもらおうとまっすぐ走れますそのほかにも今これ工程さん
高いところ低いところがわかったりあるいは速度が速かったり遅かったりというのが
分かっている
そういうものに
ありました
実際んですねあの畑で使っていただくとこんな感じです
これですねあのえっ家の近くに打つギアはさんと言って開発協力していただいている
農家さんなんですけど
縁にですね大プロ加えて撃っ
ame
すごいですよねちょっと早足になってるチャカチャカしたんですけどこんな感じでです
ねタブレットと落雷ポンポンとつけて電源を本当入れてこうすると作業ができる
とても簡単に使い教
それから見るとこんな感じです
これには耕しているところなんですけれども横乳ですね飛び飛びに線が引かれています
これはその
今いる場所がちょっとわかるのでこぼして
次の次のここに行くりですね大きくもあることでずっと前進し続けながら作業できる
まぁこんな感じですね
になっています
これだけでももう率が結構わかる子パーセントが手帳パーセントくらい上がるという
ふうに言われていくぞ
この次これはですねあの今もよく燃えてるんですが右側から泊まっていくのが分かり
ますでしょうか
1個ずつですねそうするスプレー地でもと思います
これ畑が実はな鍋なんですけれども斜めの畑で先にですね外がお
1回走るこんな感じでどこが重なっているかがわかります
重なってきたらこのしたりスイッチがあるのでそれをパチンパチンと止めていくと無駄
にならない2階ですねは辛くてます
いうような法律的に使えるよう無駄遣いしなくてもいいよとそういうことにも使える
ような
おかげさまでえっとアプリとしてダウンロードしていただくのは今大堤10万人くらい
の方々にダウンロードしていただいています
まあ
国それで行く100訴えて140カ国
演武皆さんの使っていただいている距離を後継すると台で五木日九州ぐらいが多いとき
ですね
いう形になりました
今僕たちはえーっ
もっと安い gps を作ろうあるいはもっといろんな
高度な作業ができるようなそういう新しい
この農業経営を走っとするようなハードウェアをつくったりあるいは
手放しでですねまっすぐ走るというような
モーター付きのハンドルをですね国内の用機械メーカーさんと共同で
これから出していこうというふうに取り組んでいます
そして僕ら最後にですね東最後というかこの先以外にこんな形で
1人で複数台
使えるようにしようあるいはそのそれも
メーカーを問わずそして陳宮新しいトラックただけじゃなく古い今お手持ちの
トラクター日本とつけると自動で走るようになりますよというものを作ろうというふう
にしています
今あのそうするとですね何が起こるかというと今まで農業機械を買い替えるときはだり
たいですねより大きな
農協機会に買い替えるのはでです
どうしてかというと人が必ずその農業機械に乗らなくてはいけないから
ですのでどんどんどんどん今まあ日本だけではなくて世界中で同郷機会が大きく大きく
なっていっています
そうするとどういうことが起こるかというと地面が耐えられなくなってきている
どんどん
大きな機械で地面をセットします叩きを通じ潰しますこうすると地面の下何十センチか
のところに固い固い層ができますそれを次の年
大きな大きなナイフでもう1回深く
という作業が最初に立地
透かしながらこの子強くなくただ椅子という作業で農業に購入するエネルギーの半分
以上を使っている
本当にどんどん大きくなってほんとん
潰しては倉木潰しておくだけということをしていますおまけに多いことを繰り返して
いくと
土はあんねんながら少しずつ痩せ
地面が耐えられなくなってき
をたちはそれをより小さい機会が複数台走ることで地面に優しい
畑に優しいあるいは a もちろん懐にもですね環境にを懐にもやさしいというような
技術に育てようと思っ
いません
ええまあそれともう一つ並行して今の自分を化技術新しい農業というものを
届けていきたいなというふうに思います仕事やって行ったときにみなさん何か
いやー8
実行にやるじゃないとか心がこもってないんじゃないとかそういうことを
ことがあるかも知れませ僕は役だと思ってい
農業機械に載るのか大作業でははありません
農業というのはまあ
作物をすごいかに育てておいしく食べてもらう
重い
大倉が麻痺あの皆さん
その a
あっているかな
取り組みというかそういうチャレンジを支えていけたらなというふうに思っている
ところですこれからですねあの
それがなんていうかなこのサイトさらに先に食べる人と創る人がつながるそういう未来
が
実現できるその
支えになる記述を作るのに正館張っていければなというふうに思っているところです
これから皆さん
この先ですねあの大から取り組みあったりあるいは技術というものをお目にかかれる
ことを話し日あります今日ありがとうございました
[拍手]